et c'est vrai que on a pris tous les
deux vous aviez ça impacte avant le
début de l'émission c'est quoi votre
pacte en fait on avait on avait tiré des
leçons de notre premier koh lanta et
puis marc savait que si on allait sur
cette aventure avec les valeurs que don
cherry tous les jours au quotidien c'est
à dire de l'honnêteté la sincérité on va
pas gagner c'est impossible avec les
valeurs de l'honnêteté il faut pas
longtemps bien on a dit bon écoute on va
koh-lanta c'est à menton est un jeu de
stratégie alors on a inversé parce que
moi j'ai pour moi j'allais à koh lanta
pour faire des épreuves jouer la venturi
siens mais on a bien compris en tout cas
pour ma part j'avais bien compris que
c'était d'abord un jeu de stratégie dans
laquelle il y avait des voix là où il y
avait des épreuves donc du coup à partir
du moment où on l'a compris et bien on
s'adapte et on se bat et donc le pacte
céder même s'il y avait des aventuriers
ne pas créer de conflits par exemple si
on n'était pas dans la même équipe
aucun conflit 2
de dire à tous même aux plus mauvais
qu'ils étaient très forts finalement
corps ouais ouais non mais il fallait
pas créer de conflit et le but c'était
d'aller à la réunification côté vu qu en
hypocrisie quoi on était persuadé de ne
pas retirer dans la même équipe c'était
sur moi dans mon équipe je critique il
ya sin à mourir oui si c'est ça c'est ma
stratégie un mytho cinar viviani j'aime
pas comme ça c est donc mais aussi je
sais enfin moi je me savais très bien
car une question voilà ans alors on
alors être ensemble et qu' il n'y aurait
pas eu